let's get into audience questions for
the week starting with hey David what do
you believe is the future of the
progressive movement in the Democratic
Party or is the future of American
progressivism outside of the Democratic
Party so there's a philosophical debate
here there's an ideological debate to be
had about will the Democratic Party
allow itself to become a truly
progressive party or will it not allow
that meaning that if progressives want a
real foothold in the United States they
will have to work outside the Democratic
Party as third party candidates or
whatever else the case may be beautiful
conversation I love it completely
irrelevant if if campaign finance is not
reformed and arguably if we don't
actually change our system of Elections
away from a first-past-the-post
winner-take-all system I think that if
you look at the Tea Party movement of
2010 if the Tea Party movement had
decided to work exclusively outside of
the Republican Party instead of just
having tea partiers run as Republicans
had the tea party succeeded at taking
seats it actually would have weakened
the Republican Party and by its very but
by by the inverse it would have
strengthened the Democratic Party why is
that if the tea party candidates were
not running as Republicans they would
have been running against Republicans
they would have disproportionately taken
votes from Republicans they would have
played spoilers for Republicans and they
likely wouldn't have won as many seats
either right so you would have had some
cases where Republican seats would have
been lost to tea party seats as third
party errs and that would have weakened
the Republican Party you also would have
had seats that a tea partier running
inside the Republican Party could have
won but would not have because
Republican money would have poured into
the Republican candidate and not the tea
party candidates so because campaign
finance is what it is and because we
have a voting system that is what we
have the Tea Party won a bunch of seats
in 2010 in the midterms because they ran
as Republicans at the local level some
didn't but nationally they ran as
Republicans eventually the Tea Party
became integrated into the Republican
Party and the Republican Party overall
was moved towards the Tea Party this was
a massive win for the Tea Party you
don't really hear much about the Tea
Party anymore it's just part of the
Republican Party at this point in time
that's an example of a success at
changing the party now there's an
argument to be made that Democrats are
not Republicans that the Democratic
Party would not ever be so influenced by
a progressive wing like the Tea Party
was able to influence the Republican
Party because they're just fundamentally
different parties I completely disagree
with this and the evidence is look at
how the Democratic Party has already
moved in the last five years since
Bernie Sanders in 2015 started more
prominently talking about Medicare for
all free college to a lesser extent then
more in 2020 minimum wage increase a lot
of the stuff that was made prominent by
progressives back in 2015 2016 2017 is
now relatively mainstream in the
Democratic Party now there is no
question that because the Democratic
Party as much as the Republican Party
are very corporate influenced
establishment parties you still see you
know a majority of Democratic senators
don't support something like Medicare
for all right now but I think the
evidence is clear that the progressive
wing progressives have already
influenced the Democratic Party so my
position is if we don't change campaign
finance move to public funding of
Elections limit the duration of a
campaign limit how much money can be
spent eliminate PACs all that different
stuff
I don't believe progressives have a
serious chance outside of the Democratic
Party it pains me to say it there's
actually also a backfire risk if
progressives outside of the Democratic
Party did a good job of taking some
seats away from Democrats running
independent third party in the short and
even medium term it probably helps
Republicans
by strengthening them in comparison to
the Democratic Party the progressive
wing these progressive independents
would be too small to really get very
much done in the long term it's a
question mark and we don't know so right
now if progressives were to break off
and form their own party it could very
much damage the Democratic Party if
you're an acceleration estate if you
prefer Trump / Biden if it can't be
Bernie then maybe you like that maybe
you want to see the Democratic Party
destroyed in order to at some point in
the future build it back up that's a
philosophical discussion in practice I
don't see any way that if we if we don't
reform public campaign finance and if we
don't reform how our election systems
work I don't see any way that
progressives succeed at the national
level local is different by working
outside the Democratic Party go go
bigger than the Democratic party of
course but in terms of electoral
politics you've got a fixed campaign
finance and how we do elections first if
you want progressives to have a shot
outside the Democratic Party at really
making an influence one of our sponsors
is privacy calm they're giving you $5
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm / Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up any time you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual
card number right after using it which
for instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman